In this video, I'm going to share the most common
way to get out of an awkward conversation which is
also perhaps the most terrible way to get out of
an awkward conversation. I'm also going to share
three strategies that are way better that you can
use and apply in your own context and situation
to get out of an awkward situation. My name
is Chad. I'm the co-author of this lovely book
Ask Powerful Questions Create Conversations
That Matter. And at the end of this video,
these three strategies will help you shift all of
your awkward painful heart raising conversations
into conversations that really
matter. Let's get into it.
The most terrible way and unfortunately the most
common way to get out of an awkward conversation
is to lie and make an excuse that isn't really
based in reality so, that you can just excuse
yourself. And this doesn't feel good for anybody
because even somebody with a pretty low level of
social or emotional intelligence knows when you
tell them your dog ate your homework. It feels
much better when there's some transparency that
happens. Now, the the reason that you might want
to get out of an awkward conversation is because
it's awkward. And so, to be transparent and say,
"Hey, this is really awkward. I'm going to
leave now." Is also very awkward, right? So,
you want to avoid that. And so in this video,
we're going to unpack 3 strategies that are
way better alternatives to get out of an awkward
conversation instead of lying making up an excuse
because that never feels too good. You can do
that, right? There's nothing stopping you from
doing that. But it won't feel great for you and
it definitely won't feel great for the person who
you're ditching. All 3 of these strategies that
I'm going to share became way more clear to me
after I did something that was remarkably
uncomfortable and awkward for me. Because
a big part of my job working with some of the top
leaders and educators on the planet is to invite
them to stretch outside of their comfort zone. I
think I also need to be practicing that myself as
well. And so, every year, I pick something
pretty big and uncomfortable to dive into.
And a few years ago, I signed up for a 10-day
silent meditation retreat. 10 days, no reading,
no phone, no journaling, no tv, no speaking
to anybody else. No eye contact even with
the people that they were there. Meals were
taken in silence at tables. This was like
very outside of my comfort zone. And I learned a
really phenomenal lesson in that that helped me
navigate awkward conversations. And
it was this concept of a nietzsche.
I think it's a hindi word. And it basically means
rising passing, rising passing. It's the idea
that everything is impermanent, right?And
so, at some point, if your back hurts...
At some point, it'll hurt and at some
point it won't. And at some point,
you'll feel really awkward and uncomfortable in a
conversation and at some point you won't. Making
that come alive the first strategy to get out
of an awkward conversation is to relabel it. Who
labeled the conversation awkward. It was you.
The other person might be feeling awkward in
that conversation but not necessarily. And so,
for you to label that conversation as awkward
makes it a thing, right? As soon as you put a
label to it like that, it now becomes that much
more real. And so, the first strategy is simply to
relabel the conversation and say, "This is not an
awkward conversation. This is a conversation
in progress." And when you make that shift,
all of a sudden, that conversation is changeable
and you don't need to live in that awkwardness.
Second strategy... Oh, that's going to be
really loud. Probably not going to do that.
Okay, second strategy. Shift the focus from this
person to this person. Shift the focus from you to
them. When you're labeling a conversation
awkward, that is a label that describes how
you are currently feeling because you can't
actually know how they're feeling. Now,
you might be able to pick up. There are signs
that people are feeling awkward in a conversation.
But the only way that you can really know if
something's awkward is if you're experiencing it.
And so, I found one of the most
powerful ways to shift that dynamic
is to take the focus off of yourself and
turn it onto the other person. Focus on what
they're experiencing. What would make this
conversation more interesting, more useful,
more valuable for them as opposed to focusing
on yourself of how you can get back to a place
of comfort. And I don't say that lightly, right?
Like part of my job before I started We and Me was
studying social anxiety. And so, I know that being
awkward in a conversation can be serious. It's not
just like, "Oh, this is an awkward conversation.
I want to get out of it." I recognize that some
conversations are deeply uncomfortable.
And so, these strategies are not like
flip a switch and then you just make them happen,
right? They take some some time and attention and
practice. It's like a muscle, right? And so, if
you're if you've been labeling conversations as
awkward for a long time, you need to re-label them
as in progress for a while before you're going to
start to feel like you can really shift the focus
in conversation. And practice this second strip.
Practice the second strategy of shifting the
focus away from you and on to them. The third
strategy comes from the foundational and first
chapter of our book which is... And the entire
book is structured in this pyramid framework.
The first tool concept that we share in the
book is intention. And the third strategy to get
out of awkward conversations is to put a purpose
on those conversations. Put an intention
to those conversations. In particular....
In particular, I would invite you to get clear
on what is your intention in that conversation
and share it with the other person. A lot
of times conversations feel awkward because
2 people don't know why they're in them. So,
if you think about like small talk, obligatory
small talk. You bump into somebody an event or you
show up both on 5 minutes early for a video call
and you're kind of just there, right? That might
be a place where a conversation feels awkward
to you. And I would argue it's awkward because
there's no intention or purpose established.
And so, your intention can be as simple as I'm
really curious to... Actually, that can be the
intention is curiosity. But stating that
to the person. Let's just say for example
that you bumped into somebody at an
event. You have never met them before.
You're in a conversation, you've asked
uh where are you from, what do you do,
a couple other questions that are just like in
your back pocket. They've just plugged a dvd
or a usb drive into their head and like spit out
what they said the last 15 times they answered
that question. And so, that is creating some level
of awkwardness. What I would invite you to do with
this person in the moment is get really clear
about your intention and state it. To say, "Hey,
I know typically when we're in...." This feels
very intimate. This feels strangely intimate.
If I'm in a conversation with this person,
what I'm... What my intention might be and your
intention might be different. But personally, if
I've just bumped into somebody brand new, I might
say, "Typically, when we bump into somebody at an
event like this we ask like the same 4 questions
and you give the same 4 answers. And so, I know
there's a little bit odd but I'm actually curious
to not ask those questions and I'm curious what
a highlight from the last week was for you."
There is social risk in doing something. There's
social risk in asking a question that's outside
of the norm. And yet, that conversation can go
from painful awkward obligatory small talk to
a more meaningful conversation if you take that
risk and actually state your intention to that
person. This video was fun to shoot. I hope it
was fun to watch. If you want to get out of all
awkward conversations in the future, there's
a link below with a free excerpt from our book
Ask Powerful Questions Create Conversations
That Matter. In that excerpt, there's a whole
bunch of tools that will help you have much
more intentional, meaningful conversations.
Also, the 2 videos linked here will help you dive
a little bit deeper as well. Have an awesome day.